seguimos con ustedes en esta transmisión
especial de france 24 ahora de la mano
de rosa pérez mandé para hacer un repaso
de los medios y lo que han titulado en
las últimas horas y queremos empezar en
rosa con la cronología de que es el más
emblemático el primer anuncio sobre el
comprometido de estado de salud de
isabel segunda a cargo de la bbc
exactamente hola angela a las 1240 más o
menos hora británica 2 de 40 de la tarde
la bbc interrumpía su programación con
un anuncio que ha acogido el mundo un
poco por sorpresa y es que la
presentadora de la bbc- informaba de que
el buckingham palace había emitido un
comunicado en que decía que los médicos
de la reina estaban extremadamente
preocupados por su estado de salud y
bien este comunicado ha encendido las
alarmas porque si bien se han conocido
en los últimos meses pequeñas
complicaciones del estado de salud de la
reina el buckingham palace siempre ha
intentado quitar importancia al asunto
a raíz de este comunicado el buckingham
palace no ha hecho en ninguna otra
comunicación durante horas y por lo
tanto se han abierto todas las
preocupaciones y especulaciones no a
raíz de lo que podía estar sucediendo a
la reina y si estas eran las últimas
horas algo que finalmente se ha
confirmado si te parece angela empecemos
viendo este primer anuncio esta primera
interrupción de la emisión de la bbc-
recordemos a las 1240 hora de londres
en el chat
we had news from página bienvenidos a
views de la bbc- one hemos recibido
noticias desde buckingham palace de que
la reina está bajo supervisión médica
los doctores se preocupan por su salud y
está en estos momentos bajo la
supervisión médica en el palacio de
balmoral sabemos que está tranquila y
que los miembros de su familia más
cercana han sido informados con las
noticias de que está bajo supervisión
médica aumenta así la preocupación por
su estado de salud edad ni extensión de
médicos y profesión racing con sants for
health
después de este anuncio angela como
decíamos no hemos tenido más información
durante horas y todos los ojos alrededor
del mundo estaban puestos en lo que
decía la bbc- que al mismo tiempo
anunció la interrupción de su
programación habitual y dijeron que no
la volverían a retomar tal y como estaba
establecida hasta las 6 de la tarde
durante este lapso de tiempo durante
estas horas la bbc- ha ido conectando
con el palacio de buckingham en londres
pero también con el palacio de balmoral
donde se encontraba la reina isabel
segunda en escocia y donde hemos podido
ir viendo como llegaban los distintos
miembros de su familia y un poco todo el
mundo con el temor de que sería ya una
vez con una familia reunida al completo
cuando se daría a conocer cuál era el
estado finalmente de la reina isabel
segunda y ha sido poco antes de las seis
de la tarde insistimos hora británica
cuando el periodista edwards de la vivir
si también ha interrumpido de nuevo la
emisión con otro anuncio que vamos a ver
a continuación pero fijémonos sobre todo
porque es revelador de como la propia
emisión de la bbc- ha formado parte de
este momento histórico pues la
solemnidad con la que hablan sus
presentadores veamos este primer anuncio
en que la antena de la bbc- pasa de
proyectar la bandera a media asta del
palacio de buckingham lo que ya era un
señal inequívoco del fallecimiento de
isabel segunda al estudio de la división
hace unos instantes el buckingham palace
anunció la muerte de su majestad la
reina isabel segunda del palacio acaba
de publicar un comunicado que dice que
la reina murió plácidamente esta tarde
en balmoral desde el rey y la reina
consorte permanecerán en balmoral esta
noche y regresarán a londres mañana
en los últimos minutos del palacio de
buckingham anunció la muerte de la reina
isabel 2a
para recapitular en el comunicado la
reina murió plácidamente en balmoral
esta tarde el rey carlos y la reina
consorte permanecerán en balmoral esta
noche y regresarán a londres mañana
nos levantamos con esta noticia de un
delicado estado de salud de la reina y
esto ya nos auguraba malas noticias y un
cambio de mando y después cuando
empezamos a ver a todos los familiares a
toda la familia real dirigirse hasta el
palacio de balmoral eh pues esto era
casi que una señal inequívoca de lo que
estaba pasando después nos enteramos
rosa de que el histrión se fue informada
a aproximadamente unas dos horas antes
de que fuera anunciado oficialmente el
deceso de la reina isabel 2a y
entretanto pues se está organizando todo
dentro de los medios nacionales e
internacionales para poder salir con la
noticia nosotros incluidos y la bbc por
supuesto pues después de un anuncio
digamos mucho más
sólido más exacto sí exactamente como
bien decías todo ha seguido el llamado
protocolo de la caída del puente de
londres no todos los pasos que estaban
pautados desde los años 60 a pesar que
se han ido actualizando sobre los pasos
a seguir precisamente tras el
fallecimiento de la monarca británica y
precisamente siguiendo estas pautas la
bbc- después de dar este primer anuncio
pasa a unas imágenes que ya eran de
esperar las indicaba este protocolo de
la reina isabel segunda en distintas
ceremonias en distintas recepciones
oficiales unas imágenes que estamos
viendo aquí detrás y mientras iban
proyectando estas imágenes en la antena
el mismo periodista edward se iba dando
algunas informaciones sobre la larga
vida estos 96 años de vida de isabel
segunda como por ejemplo o no que se
convirtió en reina el 6 de febrero de
1952 como decías anteriormente no estaba
destinada a cuando nació a ser reina en
un primer momento sin embargo se se
convirtió en reina después de la muerte
de jorge sexto de su padre que tampoco
tenía que ser el rey sino que su hermano
eduardo octavo abdicó porque la familia
real no le permitió casarse con su amor
con su pareja wallis simpson y de esta
forma finalmente isabel segunda se ha
convertido en una de las reinas más
emblemáticas del mundo como decíamos se
enteró mientras estaba en kenia y a su
coronación un año después la fue seguida
por bein millones de personas de hecho
ella misma decidió abrirla al pueblo
británico y fue por primera vez
retransmitirá a través de la televisión
de la bbc- precisamente esta radio
televisión británica tan vinculada a la
historia del país por otro lado también
mencionan que estuvo 73 años casada con
el príncipe felipe hasta su muerte en
abril de 2021 también hablan de charles
quien ya es rey carlos tercero que nació
en
1948 y también acaban este repaso
diciendo que en febrero de 2022 fue el
séptimo el 70 aniversario de su reinado
y una vez acaban estas imágenes sí que
ya la vivís y pasa a este anuncio
solemne para él por el que preguntabas
no ya que van fundido a negro una
interrupción ahora sí clarísima de la
emisión veamos la continuación
sting timing está
crisis la vivencia interrumpe su
programación habitual para brindarle un
anuncio importante
entonces vivir sin ir sumando esta es la
bbc news de londres buckingham palace
anunció la muerte de su majestad la
reina isabel celeste en un comunicado
del palacio declaró que la reina murió
plácidamente esta tarde en balmoral el
rey y la reina consorte permanecerán en
balmoral esta noche y regresarán a
londres mañana y vice televisión está
emitiendo este programa especial
cubriendo la muerte de su majestad en
dallas versión
off
[Música]
dios salve a la reina' reza hasta el
momento del himno algo que ahora tendrá
que cambiar yo lo decía ya lo decía el
introduce en su declaración su última
frase fue dios salve al rey carlos
tercero y dicho esto vamos ahora con más
repaso de la prensa rosa y un dato más
la bbc está cumpliendo 100 años este ha
sido un año bien movido y no olvidemos
tampoco que fueron 25 años desde la
muerte de la princesa diana exactamente
y también toda la retransmisión del
jubileo de platino de la reina que
también fue retransmitido pues muy
seguido por la cadena británica y
también alrededor del mundo y allí ya
vimos de hechos algunos indicios no de
cuando la reina no pudo asistir a todos
los eventos no bueno vamos ahora a la
prensa británica con el de guardián
comencemos dice isabel segunda la más
longeva monarca de inglaterra murió a
los 96 años y este es un titular que
encontramos de forma muy recurrente a lo
largo y ancho del mundo y es que es muy
difícil abrir una cabecera un medio de
comunicación que no esté titulando
con esta información
viene
y esto
226 2022 96 años de edad si lo titulan
la familia real y la nación de luto y
como decíamos seguramente gente de luto
alrededor del mundo y algo que
comentábamos no también la logística que
van a tener que enfrentar las
autoridades británicas por así londres
de repente se colapsa de gente que
quiere decir el último adiós a isabel
segunda esto es uno de los temores y una
de las claves que gestionar en los
próximos días hasta que se celebre el
funeral dentro de unos diez días
aproximadamente y no olvidemos que
estamos en época de post pandemia
recuperando lo que deben ser los
protocolos la logística de los grandes
se ve en todo eso de que empezaron a
retomar recientemente y habrá que ver
qué tan preparado está el reino unido
para asumir un evento de esta
envergadura justamente en este momento
de la historia y además de rózsa también
hay que decirlo cuando en europa se está
viviendo también la guerra de ucrania
vamos a hablar de the times sí que dice
muere la reina isabel segunda de nuevo
es titular inequívoco y al que no hace
falta añadirle más palabras destaca la
mujer que movió la monarquía al bando
correcto de la historia y es que a pesar
de que isabel segunda se le haya
atribuido una neutralidad política
irreprochable al menos públicamente sí
que ha habido episodios en particular
como cuando se supo a través de un
artículo del sunday times' que estaba en
contra que estaba opuesta a la posición
que había adoptado la entonces primera
ministra margaret thatcher respecto a no
participar de las sanciones a sudáfrica
para digamos sancionar a ese país
africano respecto a su política del
apartheid no ese fue uno de esos
momentos excepcionales en la trayectoria
de la reina en que se dio a conocer
digamos su posición política de standard
evening dice la reina murió a los 96
años la nación lamenta la pérdida de la
monarca
y vemos que también es pues las portadas
de financial times dejarán de escocia de
belfast telegraph por supuesto pues
digamos monotemáticas pero todas muy
solemnes y todas siendo no solamente la
noticia del día en reino unido sino
alrededor del blog exactamente y un poco
los adjetivos que se le atribuyen todos
son buenas palabras por parte de la gran
mayoría no de cabeceras tanto británicas
como internacionales por ejemplo el
financial times que comentabas dice la
gracia humanidad y fortaleza de la reina
o el general de escocia
también tiene un titular muy escueto muy
la reina isabel murió en balmoral pero
tanto el herald escocia como el beldad
fas telegraph de irlanda del norte no en
estos momentos dedican halagos y buenas
palabras a la reina isabel segunda y
hablando sobre la como envuelto de pues
también se pronuncia desde australia ni
'toronto star' quiere dice en estos dos
medios pues estos dos medios también van
en la línea de dedicarle buenas palabras
a pesar de que en la reina isabel
segunda es su jefa de estado tanto de
australia como de canadá
no tenemos que olvidarlo ciertas
corrientes republicanas dentro de estos
países pero en todo caso ahora mismo de
inmediato no ha sido el momento de
destacarlo
en los medios internacionales que hemos
hecho un poco un repaso con nuestros
corresponsables tenemos por ejemplo new
york times' comenzamos por allí que dice
la monarca que más tiempo reinó en el
mundo tenemos también el país de españa
también una monarquía y dice
precisamente referente de la monarquía
europea fallece a los 96 años tras siete
décadas al frente de la corona británica
por otro lado para volver a eeuu tenemos
el 'washington post' que llama isabel
segunda símbolo de estabilidad en reino
unido- y a nivel mundial mientras que el
frankfurter allgemeine a me dice a
menudo invisible pero omnipresente y
esta invisibilidad en relación a esta
modestia que comentábamos lo que se le
atribuye esta neutralidad política al
menos de cara a la galería' un reinado
que terminó en la calma después de la
dificultad en la que empezó hoy de la
sorpresa sobre todo en la que empezó con
una joven princesa de 26 años y quisiera
que ross a hacer una pausa para retomar
algo de esas palabras que ella dijo en
su primera intervención cuando fue
notificada ante todos vosotros declaró
que mi vida entera sea larga o corta
estará dedicada a vuestro servicio y al
servicio de la gran familia imperial a
la que todos pertenecemos esto dijo la
princesa por radio desde ciudad del cabo
donde se encontraba en sudáfrica de gira
con el príncipe de con el duque de
edimburgo y esto sucedió un 21 de abril
de
1947 así que bueno lo que hay es
historia para hacer el repaso de lo que
fue la vida y la obra de isabel segunda
como un símbolo del reino unido y de la
monarquía tenemos también el país y
washington post' efectivamente y en
relación a lo que decías no como empezó
de forma inesperada autor violenta y la
palabra más destacada del comunicado que
ha emitido el buckingham palace y que
han repetido los medios de comunicación
alrededor del mundo ha sido éste
peaceful y no esté plácidamente la reina
murió fácil plácidamente finalmente en
escocia en su cama rodeada de su familia
y como bien decías el país el
'washington post' pues todos digamos la
alaban estas siete décadas de reinado de
isabel segunda
y también tenemos informaciones de
medios rusos y de china que tampoco se
han quedado atrás vladimir putin
reconoció la innegable pérdida para el
reino unido y para la historia de la
humanidad pero vamos a védomosti de
rusia y rte que es el medio estatal ruso
exactamente védomosti señala que de
acuerdo con sondeos recientes más del 62
por ciento de los británicos están a
favor de preservar la institución sin
embargo señala que los conservadores y
las generaciones de más edad son más
propensas a digamos querer preservar la
monarquía que no los jóvenes o las
personas de una ideología más liberal o
progresista por otro lado rt ya titula
sí como distintos medios con carlos
tercero se convierte en el nuevo monarca
monarca británico a los 73 años mientras
que el 'global times' de china dice se
limita a decir que la reina británica
isabel segunda muere a los 96 años tras
ser la monarca de reino unido durante
las últimas siete décadas vemos que en
todos los rincones del planeta circula
esta información y le agradezco ustedes
por traernos los de manera tan
organizada vamos a finalizar con
latinoamérica el universal de méxico
folk ya de sao paulo de brasil el clarín
de argentina también se han pronunciado
los presidentes latinoamericanos
expresando sus condolencias al reino
unido
así es empezamos para hacer terminar
este repaso rápidamente por la prensa
internacional con el universal de méxico
que dice este jueves la reina isabel
segunda murió a los 96 años de edad
también de cita parte del comunicado del
buckingham palace de este murió
plácidamente y ya destaca que miles de
personas se congregan en torno al
buckingham palace lo que decíamos no
esta afluencia que se espera
multitudinaria en la capital británica
para dar un último adiós a la reina
isabel segunda la fue la de sao paulo
dice el reinado más duradero de la
historia también señalan carles tercero
es el nuevo rey tras 70 años como
príncipe profesional de ciertamente y
clarín han de argentina destaca el
primer comunicado del nuevo rey carlos
tercero con la cita es un momento de
máxima tristeza y hacen a numerosos
artículos como todos los medios de
comunicación
ellos se dicen que el reinado de isabel
segunda estuvo marcado por un gran apoyo
popular y es un poco de las incógnitas
si carlos tercero va a poder mantener
este apoyo popular a la monarquía
británica también a clarín le dice la
historia de su debilidad por los perros
korge y sus excéntricos cuidados es que
era una gran amante de los animales
también destaca su pasión por los
caballos y bueno esa es la noticia del
día de hoy el fallecimiento de la reina
isabel es de segunda en el reino unido
después de 70 años ocupando el trono del
país falleció en escocia este 8 de
septiembre en horas de la tarde se dio
el anuncio y estuvo acompañada de sus
familiares más cercanos que rápidamente
se trasladaron hasta el reino unido- y
hasta el palacio de balmoral le falleció
en paz esa es la comunicación oficial
que llegó a nosotros el primero por la
bbc y por los medios red nacionales del
reino unido junto a sus seres queridos y
más cercanos ahora su hijo carlos en
adelante será conocido como el rey
carlos de tercero y asumirá el trono y
la jefatura de estado así como la tarea
de seguir viviendo los cambios el reino
unido- ahora también con una nueva
primera ministra rosa el agradecimiento
es para usted muchas gracias